new york city has a new mayor his name
is eric adams and the media has sort of
been framing this guy as a moderate he's
not like full-on lefty socialist maniac
bill de blasio he's a moderate and he's
going to be pro-police and he's going to
be for cleaning up the city and doing
something about the homelessness and the
drug use and all of that stuff that's
the way it was framed well then this
past weekend yesterday sunday eric adams
went on jake tapper's show on the
entertainment network cnn
and started talking about allowing
non-citizens to vote in new york city
you announced last night that you're
going to support a law passed last month
in new york city which will allow
roughly 800 000
legal
non-citizens to vote in local elections
provided that they've lived in new york
for at least 30 days you previously
called the bill problematic and
expressed concern about giving a right
to vote to non-citizens who have only
been here for a short amount of time why
did you change your mind and why is it
acceptable for non-citizens to vote in
an american election
no i did not change my mind i supported
the concept of the bill the one aspect
of that i had a problem with and i
thought was problematic was the 30-day
part of being in the country for 30 days
was the place that i had questions and i
sat down with my colleagues i'm a big
believer in uh conversation we have to
start talking to each other and not at
each other and after hearing their
rationale and their theories behind it i
thought it was more important to not
veto the bill or get in the way at all
and allow the bill to move forward
doesn't the bill just make a mockery of
the idea of american citizenship though
i mean this is just for local elections
but does that mean like next uh new york
city is going to want non-citizens to
vote in federal elections i mean
what do you say to all the people who
went through the process the difficult
process of becoming an american citizen
studying for the test swearing an oath
of allegiance to the united states of
america who who now see this legislation
just saying well
anyone who's here all right so first off
i'll give credit where credit is due
although i don't think jake tapper is
great and he is basically a democrat
operative pretending to be a journalist
he sometimes does get some things right
i'd say he's he bats like a hundred he's
like one out of ten he gets some things
right so his questions were good there
eric adams just said complete nonsense
and lies there so he was basically like
oh i was sort of always for this i was
concerned about the 30-day thing but
then once i sat down and heard the
activists theories well then i realized
30 days in the country yeah you can vote
in new york city think how really crazy
this is and i i lived in new york city
from about 2000 to 2015.
so most of my adult life actually i was
living in new york city i was in new
york city for 9 11.
i loved new york city right if you can
make it there you can make it anywhere
like new york city should be the best
place on earth it is it is a far cry
from that right now this man is saying
that 800 000 people who are not legally
here in this country who do not deserve
the rights and privileges of being an
american that they can vote in the city
and his whole thing was oh but i i
didn't want the 30-day thing like if you
were here for 31 days then it would be
okay
but really think about what he's saying
that means if you can just figure out
how to get in through mexico and you
just make it to new york city and you're
here for
four weeks basically right
one month you can vote you can actually
influence elections and influence policy
over people who have been here this
entire time you look people you gotta
leave blue cities you really should
leave blue states if you're saying but
you've got to leave the big cities
because more and more of this nonsense
is coming and this guy was framed as the
moderate he was the one that was going
to back the police now we see that kind
of going away he was the one that was
going to make sure that you weren't
going to have this nonsense also the way
jake tapper framed it i just gave him
credit but i'll take a little credit
away he calls them legal non-citizens
legal non-citizens do you see the
orwellian language that these people use
it's really extraordinary but adam's
already has a corruption scandal on his
head we've got some info from the daily
news
mayor adams went on the defensive sunday
over prominent appointments for his own
brother and a former high-ranking cop
implicated in a bribery scandal he said
his office was seeking a waiver from the
city's conflicts of interest board to
allow sibling bernard adams to take a
high-ranking nypd job after the brother
had already joined the city payroll so
he's basically making his brother who is
unqualified from another state a
high-ranking
person in the new york police department
so it's like this is what these people
do and i am sorry
to my few sane liberal friends who are
left who thought they were getting the
moderate and thought that the crazy
socialist bill de blasio
was on his way out and the city was
going to turn around these people it's
just like la it's like california they
want more corruption they want more
lawlessness they want more illegals
voting they don't want people to show
ids when they're voting like it's so
it's all so crazy that the answer in my
estimation isn't oh let me stay here and
fix it the answer is to do what i did
and to take your skills if you're
watching this from new york city if
you're watching this from la take your
skills your passion your family
the value that you bring to the world
and find a place that is in line with
your views
but aoc you can't come here want to be
very clear about that you cannot come
here